فشروا في الاتفاق على تزويد اوكرانيا
بدبابات اليو بارك ومسؤول الامريكيه
يدعوكيف لشني هجوم مضاد بدل التركيز على
ضخمه
العفو الدوليه تحذر من استمرار الاعدامات
ايران وبرلماني ايراني
يعترفوا بتنامي الغضب الدولي من النظام
الامم المتحده تتحدث عن تراجع نهائي لحقوق
النساء في افغانستان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الى اهم الانباء من العربيه على
الرغم من فشل الحلفاوي
الالمانيه في بولندا
صوت امريكا
وكما تشاهدون على عواجل العربيه مسؤول
روسيه تهموا الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
بارسال القناصه الى اخر صون لمساعده
القوات الاوكرانيه هناك في مواجهه القوات
الروسيه من التفاصيل حول تلك التصريحات
خلال عشره
ايام
اكيد سيدعمرون
اوكرانيا
من اجل تحقيق انتصارنا اجل لا يزال يتوجب
علينا الكفاح من اجل تسلم الدبابات
الحديثه لكننا نوضح كل يوم انه لا بديل عن
ات قرار بشان تسليم الدبابه
خلاف الماني امريكي حول ارسال دبابات
لاوكرانيا
برلين تشترط ارسال امريكا دبابه ابرمز
لكيف لترسل دباباتها اليوم
[موسيقى]
المانيا
الشرط لكن بيان البنتاجون اكد
البنتاجون رد بان دبابه ابراز باهضه الثمن
وتحتاجه لصيانه الدقيقه
دبابه ابره تحمل محرك النفاثا يعمل بوقود
الطائرات
دبابه ابرمز تحتاج احد عشر لترا من وقود
الطائرات لقطع مسافه ميل واحد
دبابه ابرامز تحتوي على معدات معقده يصعب
التدرب عليها
[موسيقى]
دبابه
تعمل بمحرك ديزل
[موسيقى]
تحمل مدفع عن عياره 120 ملم
تضم تقنيات تمنح مزيدا من الامان والقوه
نطاق منها
قادره على اختراق الدروع الاماميه للدبابه
السوفياتيه السنه تي 72 على مدار كم
في التطورات الميدانيه ايضا اعتبر رسولنا
باركيهن على اوكرانيا الا تركز على الدفاع
على مدينه محمود وتحاول الاستعداد لجنه
هجوم مضاد في الجنوب ورا المصور الكبير في
اداره بيدر ان الاولويه المعطى للقتال في
بخموط تعرق اوكرانيا في مهمتها الاساسيه
المتمثله في التحضيري لهجوم استراتيجي ضد
القوات الروسيه في جنوب البلاد خلال
الربيع معتبرا ان اطاله مده القتال في
بخموط تعزز وضع روسيا التي تمتلك امكانيات
المدفعيه عدديه من ناحيه المقاتلين واضاف
المسؤول الذي طالب عدم ذكر اسمه ان انتصار
روسيا في بخموت لن يغير مجرى الحرب بل
سيمكن القوات الاخرانيه من الانسحاب الى
مواقع يسهل الدفاع عنها
على مدينه
الاستفاده من برامج التسليح والتدريب من
اجل تشكيل مزيد من الوحدات عاليه الكفاء
وتوظيفها في سنه هجوم كبيره في الجرب
وفي الجانب الاقتصادي من المواجهه يستعاده
الاتحاد الاوروبي لفرض حزمه عاشر من
العقوبات على روسيا ونقلت وكاله روت عن
مسؤولين اوروبيين ان العقوبات الجديده
ستدخل حيز التنفيذ الشهر المقبل مع مرور
عام على الحرب في اوكرانيا
اعلن البيت الابيض
الحبر وصيه على اوكرانيا ينعكست على شعبه
الاوكراني بشكل كارثي خاصه على الميزان
التجاري ونسب التضخم التي اصابت دخل
المواطنين واحتياجاتهم المعيشيه
وفقا لدائره الاحصاء الحكوميه الاوكرانيه
فقط
في السوق الاستهلاكيه لاوكرانيا حوالي 27%
استمرت اسعار المنتجات المستورده وتلك
المصنوعه محليه في اوكرانيا في الارتفاع
بسبب اقتصاد الحرب السلطات الاخرانيه تعمل
جاهده على تنظيم ضبط مستوى التضخم في
السوق الاستهلاكيه خاصه بعد ارتفاع تكلفه
المنتجات المستورده والمصنعه في اوكرانيا
المهمه للحد من تصدير المنتجات الى الداخل
من ناحيه نتخذ عددا من الاجراءات لتوسيع
العرض ومن ناحيه اخرى يواصل البنك الوطني
التسعينات الثابت اما ثالثا نحافظ على
تكلفه اضافيه هامشيه ثابته على المنتجات
الغذائيه
على الرغم من ارتفاع التكلفه والتضخم
تواصل الاعمال التجاريه في اوكرانيا العمل
ومحاوله التمسك بالسوق المحلي الا ان
الامر يتطلب سياسات ونظاما جديده من
الدوله وادارات الاعمال تتوافقوا مع حاله
الحرب بامعان النظر في ارفف في المحالي
التجاريه ومحلات البقاله فالملاحظوا
اختفاء بعض السلع منها ومع ارتفاع الاسعار
اتخذ المواطن كذلك تدابير جديده لاداره
اقتصاد الاسره مما تسبب بشكل مباشر في
انخفاض نسبه لقوه الشرائيه في السوق
الاوكرانيا
الاسعار ولا حط اختفاء العروض الترويجيه
بالنسبه لي الاسعار ليست مشكله الاكبر
لاننا سناكل شيئا اخر كبديل فقط نتمنى ان
تنتهي الحرب بشكل اسرع
بنسبه 1.7 لا سيما بسبب العواقب السلبيه
الناجمه عن الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
ارتفاع تكاليف المعيشه هو والخطر الرئيسي
للمجتمعات خلال العامين المقبلين على
الرغم من ذلك ووفقا لوزيره الاقتصاد
الاخرانيه
فان اقتصاده اوكرانيا ما زال صامدا ويتكيف
بنجاح مع ظروف الحرب وحتى مستوى التضخم في
اوكرانيا لا يزال تقريبا في ذات المستوى
بالمقارنه مع عدد من الدول الاوروبيه وضيف
عادل العربيه كيف
فيروني اعترف مرتضى محمود وانت عضو لجنه
الامن القوميه البرلمانيه
العالمي ضد نظام طهران
مع حمله المنظمه اطلقتها منظمه العفو
الدوليه
يعاني منذ وقت طويل من اضطرابات النفسيه
وقد حكم عليه بالاعدام
وبعض ريالات الدوليه الواسعه برر طهران
اعدام المسؤول الايرانيه سابق علي رضا
اكبر
وفر معلومات سريه تتعلق بقدرات ايران
العسكريه البريطانيا
الذي يحمل الجنسيه البريطانيه وتم تنفيذ
حكم الاعدام بحقه قبل ايام قدم لبريطانيا
ما وصفتها بمعلومات سريه حول سبل التفاف
طهران على العقوبات واضافه الوزاره
حول الاجهزه الامنيه والسياسيه والعلماء
البارزين مثل او مثل العالم النووي محسن
فخري زاده الذي قتل قبل ثلاثه
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الكنديه موافقتها
على اعاده 60 نساء كنديات
وثلاثه عشر طفلا محتجزين في شرمنا لشرق
سوريا منذ سنوات في اكبر عمليه اعاده داعش
تنظمها البلاد على الاطلاق قالت الخارج
يتعلق فقط بنساه واطفال المجموعه
ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد قري
تويتر تنهي خدمات 80% من موظفيها منذ تولي
الى الماسك رئاسه الشرق
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
والقدس اليوم تظاهرات ضد سياسه الرئيس
الوزراء بني امين نتنياهو وبعد الاحتجاجات
الحاشده التي شهدت تل ابيب ليله السبت
الماضيه قال زعماء او زعيم المعارضه
في نهايه هذا الاسبوع
مواجهه المباشره بين حكومه نتنياهو
اليمنيه سياسيا ودينيا مع تيار اليسار في
مدينه تل ابيب التي تعد العصب الرئيسي
للحياه الاقتصاديه لاسرائيل
ستؤثر وتهاجم الديمقراطيه تريد اضعاف
المحكمه العليا وتضر بالعلمانيه للدوله
ستمنع ايضا المواصلات ايام السبت هذا
يقلقني
الاسرائيليون يتخوفون من قرارات حكومه
نتنياهو التي تحاول فرض واقع جديد من خلال
اضعاف المحكمه العليا وفرض ايديولوجيا
اليمين المتشدد ما يؤثر على الحياه
اليوميه لدى سكانها ومن قرارات منع
المواصلات العامه في ايام السبت في تل
ابيب كخطوه غير مسبوقه
في اي دوله نريد اولادنا ان يكبروا
الاتجاه مقلق نشعر انه يخرج عن التوازن
الكثير من العمر
مشرق لاولادنا هنا اتمنى ان تتغير الامور
قريبا عشرات الالاف من تيارات مختلفه في
اسرائيل يواصلون الاحتجاج ويستعدون للخروج
غدا في تل ابيب للتعبير عن قلقهم من اكثر
حكومه يمنيه متشدده في تاريخ اسرائيل
وصفين
بالعدائيه
انقسامات داخليه
محتمل هذا ما يمكن ان تتسبب به المواجهه
الداخليه مع حكومه نتنياهو اذا استمرت في
سياستها التصعيديه التي توصف هنا
بالديكتاتوريه
من تل ابيب العربيه
العامل للامم المتحده امين محمد
للوقوف على وضع المراه في ظل قراراته
طالبه
[موسيقى]
حركه طالبان حكومه دون اعتراف دولي ولا
داخلي الا ان الحركات تمارس قمع الانسانيا
وسياسيا ومهنيا
قوانين مقيده فرضتها طالبان على المواطنين
الافغان الذين قبلوا بها مجبرين لا مخيرين
ماذا فعل الامم المتحده للتحذير من كارثه
انسانيه لانهيار سياده النظام القانونيه
دستور عام 2004 وعزلت جميع القضاه من هيئه
المحكمه وجردت مكتب المدعي العام من دوره
الرئيسي بات القسم والذي ادلى به المحامون
والقضاء حبل مشنقه تعلقه طالبان على رقاب
المعرضين منهم لاحكامها
من حقوقهن الاساسيات سواء التعليمه او
العمل او غيرهما من قبل الحركه التي لم
تستثني النظام القانوني
عمل وصفات الامم المتحده بالعمل التمييزي
الواضح حيث فصل الطالبان اكثر من 200 250
قاضيه ومئات من المحاميات والمدعين
العامين في حين هرب العديد من القضيه من
البلاد او اختبائن باتت افغانستان تحت
نظام من غير مستقله ونظام حركه تستخدم
سلاح القتل ضد من كل بتطبيق العدل اكثر من
10 مدعينين معظمهم من الرجال قتلوا على
ايدي مجهولنا ويقال ان العديد منهم ما
زالوا مختبئين
الامم المتحده قالت بان ما يتعرض له
العاملون في جهات انفاذ القانون في مقصره
طالبان يتطلب تحركا فوريا من قبل المجتمع
الدوليه لوقف تلك الممارسات التعسفيه
روان حمزه العربيه
[موسيقى]
جديده
وتسريعي عمليه رفع الحد الادنى لعدد سنوات
المساهمه في صندوق تامين التقاعدي للحصول
على معاش تقاعدي كامل
فتح حتى شرطه البريطانيه تحقيقا بعد ظهور
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشنس هناك في
مقطع الفيديو من دون حزام امان اثناء مرور
سيارته هناك اعتذر عن خلعي حزام الامان
خلال تصويره مقطعا لمتابعه على انستغرام
ومن الضروري ان يربط كافه الركابي حزام
الامان في السياره مخالفه ذلك تفرض على
صاحبها غرامه قد تصل الى 500 جنيه
هذا ما تحقق فيه الشرطه بعد ظهور رئيس
الوزراء ريشه سوناك في فيديو لا يرتدي فيه
حزام الامان فيما سيارته تتحرك سوناك
اعتذر عن خلع حزام الامان خلال التصوير
مقطع لمتابعي على الانستغرام واعتبره خطا
في التقدير سونار قد يتلقى غرامه ماليه
على هذه المخالفه الجديده بعد تغريمه 50
جنيه العام الماضي لخلقه قواعد كورونا
عندما كان وزير الماليه في عهد حكومه برج
جونسون
لا تشرع قانون
يوسف السكن
الثانيه غرامه الله بعد مخالفته القانون
مرتين في الحكومه البريطانيه الا اذا وجدت
الشرطه التبريرا المقنعا لعدم ارتداء حزام
الامان وذلك في الحالات الاستثنائيه
الصحيه المحدوده وهذا مستبعد في حاله
سوناك لا احد يستخفه بالتحديات التي
تواجهه بريطانيا من اقتصاد المتعثر وغلاء
المعيشه واضرابات تتسع عدتها والان ريشه
هناك الذي يقود البلاد في هذه المرحله
الحرجه في ازمه خاصه بسبب خلقه القانونه
خلال اداء مهامه وان لم تكن تابعتها واضحه
بعد
مصطفى زاروه العربيه لندن
غير مطالبين بربط حزام الامان خلال النشره
استغنت شركه تويتر نحوي 80% من الموظفين
منذ استحواذ الملياردير الى الماسك عليها
ويبلغ عدد موظفي شركه اليوم حوالي 1300
موظف فقط من بينهم اقل من 550 مهندسا وذلك
وفقا لقناه سي ام بي سي
حزب العمال في نيوزلندا انه سيرشح وزير
التعليم
التي تنحت عن نصيبها
في حزب العمال في البرلمان ليصبح رئيس
الوزراء الحادي والاربعين في الهجره
الاغلبيه الجمهوريه في الكونغرس الامريكي
تشريعه من الحزبين الديمقراطي والجمهوري
لانشائي فرقه مهمتها تحصينا نظام كمبيوتر
الطيران بما في ذلك اضافه تحديثات للضمان
استقرار ومرونه وامن رحلات الجول
قالت سلطات الصينيه ان ذروه موجه فيروس
كورونا في البلاد قد انتهت وذلك بتزامد مع
حركه تنقلات واسعه داخل الصين بسبب عطله
راس السنه الصينيه
من مرحله لاخرى تحاول الصين تجاوز عقبه
كورونا وبخطا مثقله باعباء الوضع الصحي
تعلن عن انتهاء الذروه موجه تفشل قاسيه
فاوفقا لنائبه رئيس الوزراء الصيني صارت
الجائحه بشكل عام في البلاد عند مستوى
منخفض نسبيا
عدد الحالات الحرجه في المستشفيات تتناقص
بشكل متضرد والجائحه اصبحت عند مستوى
المنخفض لكن مهمه الانقاذ لا تزال ثقيله
الاعلان الرسمي عن تحسن الاوضاع الصحيه
يتزامن مع عطله راس السنه القمريه الجديده
وفي يوم يعد احد اكثر ايام السفر ازدحاما
منذ فش الجائحه عام 2019 يتخوف البعض من
زياده اخرى في عدد الاصابات بسبب حركه
السفر والتنقلات تخوفات لم يخفها الرئيس
الصيني في جنبينج الاسبوع الماضي لا بد من
بدل المزيد من الجهود لتحسين رعايه الطبيه
للفئات المعرضه للاصابه بالفيروس في
المناطق الريفيه ومعالجه مواقف في الوقايه
من الاموئه في هذه المناطق
التصريحات الرسميه الصينيه تتزامن وتوجه
اليابان بخفض تصنيف كورونا الى فئه
الانفلونزا خلال الربيع القادم
لقد اكدت مع حكومتي على تعزيز المناقشات
بين الخبراء حول خطوات اعاده تصنيف فايروس
كورونا الجديده
5 في هذا الربيع ارقام المؤسسات الصحيه
العالميه تتماشى مع تحذيرات منظمه الصحه
العالميه حول تطورات كورونا في العالم حيث
اشارت الى ارتفاع نسبه الوفيات الى 20% في
الفتره ما بين ديسمبر الماضي ويناير
الجاري مقارنه بالايام 28 التي سبقت هذه
الفتره الى جانب انخفاض نسبه الاصابات
بنحو 7%
اما السلطات الصحيه الصينيه فتواصل سعيها
لاحتواء المرض كان اخره حصول شركه سينوفار
مصر الصينيه على موافقه الاستخدام لقاح ضد
متحول اوميكرون
علي السمان العربيه
العفو الدوليه تحذر من استمرار الاعدامات
في ايران وبرماني ايرانيه اعترف بتنامي
الغضب الدولي من النظام الايراني
الامم المتحده تتحدث عن تراجع نهائي لحقوق
الانسان في افغانستان
[موسيقى]